Santa Claus is coming to Netflix was the  night before Christmas and all through  the house not a creature was stirring  except for my spouse she was banging an  elf he sees when you've been sleeping  yeah I see you when you're sleeping  white guys white guys sleep like this oh  I'm a white guy I'm very excited for  Santa I hope he brings me some corduroy  slacks guys sleep like this oh yeah  black died I can't wait for Santa Claus  to bring me to fold any nose when you  needle that you saw Mommy Kissing Santa  Claus but for $9.99 a month you can see  mommy do it he's jolly  I'm not jolly I laughed this much  because of nitrous oxide these raunchy  last Christmas I thought Kevin Spacey a  Sleep Number bed yeah you know what his  sleep number is 14  Oh too soon not for Kevin Spacey it's  never too soon to look this guy's Asian  hey you're Asian but he's also got a  sensitive side cancer sack up central  line  it's really doing some of his best work  right now  you